foreign
[Music]
s of the Matrix I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report we've got another
Friday Round Table Extravaganza for you
joining me today is a fellow at the
Manhattan Institute and author of the
new book when race trumps Merit Heather
McDonald an essayist for Noble Truths
with ravarotta RAV Aurora Heather Rob
welcome to the Reuben report
fabulous to be with you thanks Dave
I'm really glad to have you both on I
said to you right before we started that
you know Heather you've been you've been
cracking and hitting and smacking around
Dei diversity equity and inclusion and
all of these uh race stats and crime
stats and all these things for many many
years and and Rob is uh sort of on Deck
now doing it right now so I thought you
guys would make a great Duo today and we
have plenty of stuff in that department
to get to uh before we do that I got one
ad for you guys and then we'll get right
to it uh let's talk about relief band
real quick you know is Joe Biden's
economy making you nauseous it's making
me nauseous well you've got to check out
relief band relief band is the number
one FDA cleared anti-nausea wristband
that's clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more whether you need everyday
nausea relief or just an occasional cure
for nausea their patented technology
makes feeling sick a thing of the past
it's like the name says relief relief
band is legitimately a band you wear on
your wrist that gives you relief from
nausea and you can change the intensity
depending on how you're feeling to make
it stronger or weaker that means no more
nausea pills that'll make you groggy and
exhausted relief band is a hundred
percent drug free and non-drowsy plus
they've got an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and over a
hundred thousand satisfied customers so
they're a brand new can trust so if you
just want to get those uh accounts
refilled if you've ordered red relief
band before go ahead and do that you
guys know that I like to polish off the
week with a little tequila and if I'm a
bit nauseous the next day it's rare but
it happens I just throw on my relief
band and the post hangover nausea is
gone go to
reliefband.com
Reuben and you'll receive 20 off
reliefband.com Reuben all right let's
get to it so uh Heather before we start
here I realized we have not spoke in
quite some time I haven't had you on
since before kovid you are in New York
right now so this wasn't really the
point of today's show but would you like
to comment on what's going on in New
York City before we get to it masks
people are still wearing masks Outdoors
they're wearing masks in my apartment
they get on the elevator they're still
using their keys to press the elevator
buttons now it's not as insane as it was
before but I despair I really do I I am
at this point fighting to hold my tongue
to not accost people on the street
asking them what will it take to get you
to turn off take off your mask we have
uh squalor everywhere there's there's uh
scaffolds erected around buildings
because of a ridiculous law that
requires Building Inspections of every
brick on a on a facade within four every
five years way over regulated we have
these grotesque restaurant shanties that
are covered with graffiti uh reflecting
tape all over that nobody's going to
take down so it's a it's really turned
into a dystopian uh Urban environment at
this point in in large part but not
exclusively
because of the pandemic
just betrayal of decent risk conscious
rational policy during covid but also
because of the issue of crime and the
reluctance to enforce the law because it
would have a disparate impact on
minority criminals
unfortunately I don't think anyone
listening is surprised by anything that
you just said there uh RAV before we get
into it you are up in Vancouver in
Canada I know it's a little crazy in
Canada these days I'll give you the same
opportunity anything you want to just
say about what's going on in Canada
before we get to it
yeah well the big thing here was the
vaccine mandates that was preventing
people from traveling and for a long
time uh going to restaurants gyms uh
large Gatherings weddings and and
traveling that is by the way
internationally and domestically on
airplane and train so they got rid of
that
um several months ago so we're you know
we're we're back to where we were before
but there are still some people who
refuse to take off their mask and our
grocery stores and outside and
University campuses you can still find
people who are engaging in this you know
very risk-averse Behavior but but I will
say I I hope my overall observation is
that most people even those that were
fairly alarmed irrationally alarmed
about covet have now kind of just moved
on because it's no longer a big issue
anymore they got vaccinated if they
wanted to and now at this point it's not
really a big issue anymore and there's
still a push by you know FDA Pfizer CDC
you know the new bivalent boosters and
just continuing push towards
um more and more medicalization but I
think most people now realize that you
know it's over now the pandemic is over
yeah all right well we're going to get
to what Pfizer is up to in just a second
I know we shouldn't be surprised by
anything these days but I'm continuously
amazed when I get on planes now where
they no longer force you to wear a mask
simply because one 35 year old Trump
appointed judge said no more masks on
planes one day and then everyone took it
off kovi did not explode I mean that
that in and of itself should have told
us everything we need to know but on
planes now as I'm sure you guys have
both noticed they always say uh you know
masking is no longer mandatory but
please respect the choices of the people
sitting around you which oddly they
never said before right when when they
weren't when they were forcing us
somehow Choice was was not relevant but
let's get cracking uh Pfizer since you
both mentioned or since you mentioned
Pfizer there Rob they are still pushing
out ads on vaccines and boosters uh for
not only uh people you know let's say
middle agesh but for young people and
pretty much everybody and they've got
celebs doing the Hawking Forum here's
John Legend
okay I know I'm talking to every parent
out there life with little kids can be a
juggling act Luna's got dance miles has
basketball plus they both have school
and their own personalities
and now we've got a little baby in the
house but I wouldn't trade being a dad
for anything in the world I love being
there for my special moments with my
kids that's why my health is such a
priority to me and why I got an updated
covid-19 booster my family did too
I encourage you to talk to your
healthcare provider and go to
vaccines.gov to check eligibility and
schedule an appointment today
all right a couple things here I don't
know how much he got paid for that but
it was obviously a paid advertisement
even though it didn't look like an
advertisement it just looked like a
selfie video in essence um just on a
personal note uh my partner David my
husband David has covid right now as do
our two a six month old and a
four-month-old and we spoke to our
pediatrician and basically she said uh
just keep giving them breast milk a lot
of love a little fresh air when you can
make sure they're elevated a little bit
when sleeping if possible and then and
they're already all on the mend the idea
that I would be injecting them with
anything or would have injected them
with this stuff beforehand is completely
insane uh Heather it's just never gonna
stop right I mean I think that's sort of
what you're alluding to and what you're
seeing in New York City that these the
ads the behaviors it seems like we've
crossed some bizarre threshold here even
though Rob is saying you know some
people are putting some of it behind but
the the general movement of this thing
seems like it's just going to keep going
forever
yes the New York Times still publishes
its weekly coronavirus update that
purportedly shows hot spots in the
country there are none you know there's
these little sort of Cloudy Dots here
and there that have maybe like three
people with covet or five people in the
hospital of course we still are counting
uh hospitalizations with covid as
hospitalizations for covidson with the
death rate but yes uh there's a there's
a core constituency committed to
safetyism it runs universities uh it's
it's highly female and they are not
willing to allow people to go back to a
sense of individual risk calculation or
governments to go to a sense of of
rational policy making that balances
costs versus risks and and
celebrates uh entrepreneurship and risk
taking instead we're all supposed to
cower under the thumb of our government
overseers
yeah Rob I assume you see it in a
somewhat similar light that even though
you're seeing some degree of people
moving past it that you know especially
for young people that's the crazy thing
the 21 year old who's supposed to be a
rebel like man they are just asking for
more and more it's such a sad state of
what of what human aging and and the the
phases in life that you're supposed to
go through are all about
um
yeah I just want to respond to the John
Legend thing by the way I mean that was
just absolute lunacy I mean I've been
covering covid particularly vaccines and
the approval and the development and the
process in which they were distributed
to the public for over a year now I mean
it's just been so egregious what's been
happening that I've had to just focus
there exclusively and sort of put
previous Prime and race issues on the
side but you know this John Legend thing
it's like you know it makes no sense
he's like you know I love being a dad I
want to be there for my kids I want to
support my family therefore I've gotten
this highly experimental fifth
roster shot with no randomized clinical
evidence no evidence of how this was
going to benefit me no idea about
adverse safety events I mean one CDC
official when asked about what the
safety profile of the bivalent vaccine
is particularly the myocarditis issue
which disproportionately affects men up
until the age of 4 at least I've been
writing about this a great length on my
sub stack because no one else will the
CDC official said we don't know but we
accept we expect a similar safety
profile for the Mario Kart it's similar
and if that's true you mean you're
compounding you know one in two thousand
or one in three thousand you know
myocarditis risk over the first second
third fourth fifth bivalent booster shot
I mean they have no idea what they're
doing and so to like this is just pure
propaganda at this point on Twitter this
big celebrity you know moving from I
love my family and want to protect them
to get this uh highly experimental
unproven pharmaceutical product where we
don't know the benefits and we don't
know the safety profile and it like it
just makes no sense for anyone to get
this thing unless they're you know
highly highly sick and even then you
know the case to make for getting the
byland booster is difficult because we
we don't really know how long this will
last you know best observational data is
showing like two three months you know
my last and you'll be at fifty percent
efficacy but it's just so much
uncertainty at this point and you can
see in that that John Legend video
um I saw it on Twitter a couple days ago
it was like two million views and like
100 likes it's like no one's getting
this thing either I mean last I've
checked the bivalent booster uptake was
something like 20 to 30 percent and
among like people under 40 to 50 it was
like lower than that right it's it's
really incredible because because
nobody's buying the not and not nobody
but in the large majority of people many
of whom who don't really get it still
even they are not buying it I had Dr
Robert Malone on uh two weeks ago who
was you know owns more mRNA technology
than anyone I mean he basically invented
this thing and what he said is that he
thinks oh no he said I don't think it he
said I know it that the vaccine injuries
are going to get much worse than what
are being reported right now and by the
way I have a I have a friend who's a
young guy in his early 20s right now who
since he got vaccinated has been having
heart problems and right now for two
weeks he's in the midst of wearing a
heart monitor so they can monitor him to
figure out what's going on there I mean
that's I know that's just one one
example but it's like this is happening
all over the country but let's continue
with with Pfizer and yeah Heather go
ahead you know the fact that males are
more susceptible to to setbacks and
disease from this is a feature not a bug
I mean we've seen how the vaccine policy
previously was was put to equity ends
and nothing is more Equitable for
society than getting rid of males
because we know that they are the source
of all evils particularly white males we
saw vaccine policy you know were some
some jurisdictions not wanting to give a
priority to elderly Americans who are
the only ones really that had much to
worry about from covid because they're
disproportionately white so this whole
covert thing has been has an upside of
being able to Cull populations that are
that are less uh politically favored at
this point I would just say Dave and you
know I'm I'm not one to at all second
guess Rob's research but I do think that
the anti-vaxxers are somewhat at risk of
using the same uh flawed thinking as the
pro-vaccine people now were before of
seizing on single cases without
necessarily a randomized controlled
experiment so I I fully I fully accept
that I'm I'm giving just one example
that happens to be in my life I actually
do have a couple other examples of young
people that I know and and people
roughly my age that are having vaccine
injuries balancing problems like uh
shingles like some weird weird stuff but
I I fully accept that but you mentioned
you mentioned the diversity equity and
inclusion part of this let me let me
throw to this image because uh since
John Legend is doing this for Pfizer
Pfizer of course also is big on Dei and
as you can see what it it says right
there diversity equity and inclusion who
we are everyone has something to offer
diverse teams are more collaborative
more accepting of different perspectives
and more representative of the world we
share RAV nothing about diverse teams
being better at research and uh maybe
making sure that the vaccines work am I
just old school on this one
yeah yeah I just want to quickly respond
to something Heather said
um I'm absolutely concerned with a
certain kind of anti-vac sentiment that
you that you would see on the fringes of
the right and the left and across the
political Spectrum
you know there are certain people who
think millions of people are dying from
the vaccine and I think that's just
ludicrous and there's certain people on
Twitter who every time someone dies
they're like oh it's the vaccine people
are dropping Dead from the vaccine so
that's absolutely a knee-jerk
ideological response that I think is
quite irrational and I know I know many
people who have fallen into that trap
but I always stick to the peer-reviewed
evidence and for the the risk of heart
inflammation for example about one in
three thousand for young males after the
second dose like that's absolutely
alarming given the incredible low
infections fatality rate and the only
re-analysis of the initial Pfizer and
moderna safety data done by Freeman and
colleagues in peer the peer review
journal vaccine top scientists from
Stanford and UCLA they found a serious
adverse event rate of one in 800 from
the initial clinical safety data and
that's in comparison to all other
vaccines that are about one per million
or one per two million yeah serious
adverse event rate so you know I stick
to the evidence and according to the
best evidence there's a lot to worry
about and there are a lot of concerns
that we're still trying to figure out
with respect to the the diversity equity
and inclusion stuff I mean you know
that's that's one great way to to
bolster confidence I mean now now not
only
now not only my my considering and
looking at a pharmaceutical uh product
that was heavily uh financially
incentivized and developed under
operation warp speed which has its
benefits arguably in an emergency
situation for elderly people but for
younger people the risk calculus is
totally different a product developed in
Rapid speed fashion uh no long-term data
initially the the only initial trials
the endpoints of those trials was
symptomatic infection not severe disease
most of the severe severe disease data
that we have is observational and now on
top of that the people that were
creating this you know perhaps or you
know however they're gonna launch this
Dei stuff for for future doses now now I
also know the people behind this stuff
are also going to be potentially
selected based on skin color based on
immutable characteristics rather than
you know the the best pharmaceutical and
scientific researchers to to create this
product Heather Shirley a lesbian latinx
black woman with a limp would be better
suited to be making vaccines than a
middle-aged white guy
well you know science is about the
scientific method and the absolute
perversity of our current age is we're
making it all about scientists it is it
is the the
enlightenment Triumph of elevating
reason beyond the particularities and
the trivialities of race and sex and
gender which I I hate to have just used
that term because it's a complete fake
uh recent concoction uh but but now
that's all that scientists are talking
about I can't tell you Dave every single
day I've I've got an oncologist who
sends me the latest uh racism is the
heart of science message from nature
Magazine from Scientific American from
Jama from his own uh pediatric facility
it is an absolute Obsession and here's
the key Dave diversity is code word for
racial preferences at some point you
have to look at this and say the lady
death protests too much why do we keep
talking and talking and talking about
diversity I can guarantee you if there
was not a large academic skills Gap and
this is very taboo to mention we have to
swallow hard and realize we're talking
about averages not individuals if there
was not a large academic skills Gap that
is impeding uh racial proportionality in
in institutions nobody would be talking
about diversity the reason we talk about
diversity is it's a covert way to to
import massive massive racial
preferences which are threatening our
Competitive Edge threatening our
scientific capacity and will eventually
put lives at risk to dumb that down
completely I'm just not for
discriminating against against young
Asian men who work very hard and try and
do everything right and I don't think
Harvard nor any medical school or any uh
business should be discriminated against
them quite simply but to really drive
your point home I saw this video
yesterday this is absolutely
mind-blowing so this is from Columbia
University this is Columbia University
Medical students chanting about critical
race Theory and a whole bunch more
listen to the tone the tenor of all of
this the repetitiveness the droning of
these clones I mean this is absolutely
Wild enjoy we enter the profession of
Medicine with appreciation for the
opportunity to build on the scientific
and humanistic achievements of the past
we also recognize the acts and systems
of Oppression affected in the name of
medicine we take the south of service to
begin building a future grounded in
truth restoration and Equity to fulfill
medicine's capacity to liberate I
promise to take care of my future
patients by engaging in dialogue
listening to their lived experience and
tailoring my recommendations to their
unique circumstances
I acknowledge the past and present
failures of medicine to abide by us
obligation to do no harm and affirm the
need to address systemic issues in the
institutions I uphold I promise to
critically examine the systems and
experiences that impact every person's
health and ability to receive care I vow
to use this knowledge to uplift my
patience and disrupt the injustices that
harm them as I Forge the future of
Medicine
I promise to self-reflect diligently to
confront unconscious prejudices and to
develop the skills knowledge and
character necessary to engender an
inclusive Equitable field of Medicine
and then they all drank the Kool-Aid and
dropped dead
um Rob I I mean I started scribbling
down some of the things wrong that we
heard there but how about just the
general tone of that the the the
lifeless tone with which the woman reads
that they read uh these are supposed to
be really bright young people who are
going to save lives Equitable medicine
sounds like you're gonna have to kill a
certain set of people I think Heather
was basically alluding to that
yo Dave that does look like a like a
pseudo-religious service I mean look
like a ceremony these people are taking
a part in you know reminds me of like
you know being little and watching like
like little kids at church having to
like repeat something that they don't
want they don't want to be there they're
kind of bored it's like these people I
don't know how many of them I actually
believe what they're saying but the fact
that they're being instructed to do
these things when that's not really
their role to examine unconscious biases
institutional corruption racism I mean
if you ask any doctor they're overloaded
with so much work to do I mean so much
overwhelming data and you know do I
recommend a drug here or a behavioral
intervention or whether it's exercise or
sleep or medication or do this test or
that test and now they're also being
told to reflect on institutional bias
like it's completely out of their
purview and I don't know why they would
start recommending doctors to do this
kind of thing
well Heather I think I think you
probably do know why right
it's because we are terrified of the
ongoing racial skills Gap and we now
would rather blame our own institutions
for Phantom racism and say that
standards are the problem rather than
that lack of of sufficient achievement
uh and we're tearing down our standards
we're tearing down gifted intelligent
programs we're tearing down standardized
tests some schools are getting rid of
the medical school admissions test
because they have a disparate impact uh
but but here's the facts again these are
the things Dave that nobody wants to
talk about but you have 66 percent of
black 12th graders not even possessing
partial Mastery of 12th grade math
skills skills that are so basic they
mean simply doing an arithmetical
calculation or being able to understand
a linear relationship on a graph so so
we have that fact that nobody wants to
look at and then we say well if if
blacks are not 13 of Harvard medical
students it must be because Harvard is
discriminating in its medical missions
which is complete a complete deception
there's not a single institution that is
not according black privilege not white
privilege no I don't know of a single
black student who's going around
checking white on his college admissions
or or graduate school or law school box
right but I do know of white students
who are wanting to be underrepresented
minorities so uh but this thing don't
think this is just a bunch of idiot
students what what this pledge was this
sort of land and race acknowledgment
sounds very much like materials coming
out of the AMA out of the American
Association of medical colleges which
are going to start certifying colleges
medical schools based on whether they
their faculty can repeat these bromides
and whether they're teaching their
students these bromides and it's all
zero-sum every moment a medical student
spends learning about intersectionality
which is a ridiculous idea is a moment
spent not learning how to save you when
you come into that emergency room after
a car crash yeah I think that's the key
point that once you bring this stuff in
you move your eyes off what the core
competency of whatever the institution
is so ultimately you will over time have
worse Pilots you will have worse doctors
you will have worse engineers and we
will wonder why people are dying of
heart attacks and why bridges are
collapsing and planes are crashing Etc
et cetera but you know as we as we were
playing that video I said to my guys in
studio I was like you know guys I'm
never leaving Florida and I forgot what
video was coming up next but we we are
booting this stuff out of Florida right
now that is what DeSantis is doing this
very week
uh Joe Contreras I'm with the Guardian
newspaper and the Washington monthly
magazine
among the areas you identify that's like
left of the left right
can I ask my question no no I mean you
can but I just I I've seen that's uh
it's interesting
why did it take you more than two years
Governor to suddenly decide that Dei
should be abolished in the State
University system thank you so it's a
good question so one it wasn't at my
direction I didn't know what Dei was a
couple years ago as this had taken hold
I mean it sounds innocuous right I
thought maybe diversity of ideas maybe
actually have more than one Viewpoint
well that's not what it is uh what it is
is it's trying to enforce a political
agenda and a political Orthodoxy under
the auspices of administration and and
that is something that that is not in
the best interest of the state but I
think if you look to see how it's worked
in practice it's been an embarrassment
to see some of the things that have come
out at Florida State at some of these
universities here it's not an
appropriate use of the administrative
Machinery of a university that oh by the
way subsists on the generosity of the
taxpayers we introduce legislation to
remedy that and we will be be the first
state in these United States to wipe out
Dei at our Public University
[Music]
[Applause]
Heather I thought there was a nice
mayakopa there at the beginning by
DeSantis when he said you know I didn't
really know what this was a couple years
ago I thought that diversity meant
diversity of ideas like this thing has
crept up on many many people but you've
really been writing about this for years
and years so you're you must be sort of
happy that people are coming around now
and doing the right thing oh you're way
too generous to me Dave actually I'm
furious that they haven't realized this
I'd be like where have you guys been you
know I'm not the only one I get that I
get that angle too I get that angle I
feel that's with something sometimes
but the fact that he's going to do
something about it that's the point yeah
better late than never and you know the
thing that is so disgusting about this
leaving aside the the
overwhelmingly uh biased and and and
fanciful portrayal of the United States
that is the core of Dei ideology the
idea that we are systemically racist now
I'm not going to deny the the white
supremacy and systemic racism of our
past it was horrible and we don't
sufficiently account for it in
conservative discourse in my opinion
nevertheless that is not a reality today
but the other issue is just the sheer
bureaucratic cost of these of these
initiatives you have bureaucrats up the
Wazoo that there is reason why tuition
keeps going up and then you have the
federal government saying oh well we're
going to take more taxpayer dollars from
you know the people in East Palestine uh
with their with their fuel spill that
our working class so the we can spend
more on college loans to prop up this
whole corrupt phony system of ever
growing bureaucracies the bloatedness of
these universities driven by the Dei
bureaucracy the whole thing is just
absolutely nauseating and they get away
with it and good for DeSantis for saying
you know what there's something we can
do about it and I'm not going to be
bludgeoned by the academic left
Rob isn't that something when you hear a
politician actually address a problem
and then clearly do something about it I
mean he's Staffing right now colleges
Chris Ruffo is here now helping out uh
you know where they're going to get rid
of Dei in some of the state schools as
as DeSantis referred to like he's
actually he's not just saying it he's
actually doing something about it
hmm I just want to quickly credit
Heather for the work she's been doing
for several years on the the racial
skills Gap I mean that's at the core of
so many of these problems and it's
bizarre just how taboo that is and I've
written about this in Colette and the
New York Post before with respect to
disparities and income between racial
groups
um and even there I've gotten a lot of
pushback for doing that thing
um for engaging in that kind of analysis
but I just credit Heather for just
continuing to to write about that stuff
it's uh it's it's not written about
enough
um the the difference in skills and
education
um with respect to the stuff at
universities I mean if you look at the
budgets for some of these people working
in Dei You Know Chief diversity officer
assistant treasury Secretary of equity
blah blah blah blah it's like hundreds
of thousands of dollars per person or
tens of thousands of dollars per person
at least I've I think it was um Mark
Perry I think he's at Ai and he's posted
some graphs on Twitter some charts
showing how much these people are making
and it's just obscene like what are we
doing with all this money like imagine
if we took all this money like I think
he was showing for one University it was
something it was like hundreds of
thousands of dollars for like five
employees or something and it's like
imagine if we could use that money and
like help fund better education in inner
city schools like help
you know incentivize better programs for
education and whatnot like like that
would be a far better usage of resources
but you know it's funny I've I've never
been able to find out how many uh young
black people BLM sent to college
very bizarre you would think that number
would be out there but I'm fairly
certain the number is zero let me just
jump to one other thing with DeSantis
related to all of this which is that
he's also now pushing a digital Bill of
Rights obviously uh you know between big
Tech censorship and algorithmic
manipulation all of the stuff that that
everybody watching this knows about uh
he's not waiting for the federal
government to do anything on it because
clearly they ain't going to do anything
so here is the Santa's same press
conference So today we're going to be
proposing and we're working with the
legislature to to enact a digital Bill
of Rights which will protect Floridians
from Big Tech harms and big Tech
overreaches uh also taking even stronger
action to address threats posed by CCP
related entities like Tick Tock but not
only Tick Tock but doing it much broader
than just state government devices and
so what is the digital Bill of Rights
well uh we want to protect your right as
a Floridian to have private in-person
conversations without big Tech
surveilling you we also are going to
protect the right to participate in
online platforms without unfair
censorship for we want free speech we
want more speech not less speech we want
to protect the right to know how these
internet search engines are manipulating
search results transparency in terms of
what we're doing so that you can
evaluate whether that's a search engine
that you want to use or maybe you want
to take your business elsewhere
Heather is this federalism at its best I
mean the feds don't seem to want to do
anything the administration we actually
know that they flag posts to silence
people's Free Speech individual people's
free speech so the states are going to
do something at least some of them yeah
if this is technically possible this is
way outside of my understanding I don't
know if this state has the capacity I'm
not saying the lawful right I would
imagine it does to make those changes
into something as massive as these
search platforms but if it can be done
it's great and I know Europe has been
trying to get more uh you use your
privacy and control over personal
information so maybe there's you know
things that that DeSantis can do but but
it's certainly a great step I mean I
noticed with that John Legend video for
Pfizer I wanted to see the comments and
there was a sign there underneath the
thing who can reply people Pfizer
follows or monitors can reply so they're
censoring there which is just classic uh
but the worst censorship of course is
for these tech companies to to silence
people who are not taking the correct
line on lockdowns or outdoor mask
wearing in the i in the in the Absurd
idea that they are following the science
and they're destroying misinformation
well you know better than anybody else
Dave is our biggest Free Speech Advocate
uh that this is a complete
misunderstanding of how the marketplace
of ideas works and how truth emerges
from conflict and argument not from
suppression you know the the point you
made on the comments being disabled are
only people who follow Pfizer can
comment that that's not nothing because
it's happening now with almost everyone
related to this for example Bill Gates
when he tweets shuts off comments uh the
head Randy Weingarten the head of the
teachers union shuts off comments Pfizer
usually does all of these people who
were told are our Elite thought leaders
who know so much better about how we
should live our lives than we know for
ourselves they don't want to hear from
any of us but we ain't gonna stop are we
rob
yeah yeah I mean I don't I don't have a
huge problem with people choosing to you
know turn off comments on their posts
but the larger issue on social media
which I've been reporting on for a year
now has been you know mainstream Pro
like even Pro vaccine scientists
tweeting peer-reviewed studies done by
ivy league you know scientists she is
showing risk of Adverse Events on
vaccines being labeled misleading or
their accounts
censored
um uh
Dr J balachari obviously at Stanford
he's a great guy his account was
blacklisted because he was on the wrong
side of lockdowns
um you know tweets being labeled
misleading but I think Dr Martin koldorf
the co-signer of the Great Barrington
declaration this tweet labeled
misleading for saying that not everyone
needs the vaccine like this is the level
of censorship we've seen online this
this this very disturbing collusion
between big Tech the government the FDA
Pfizer CDC all coming together as this
Collective entity that polices what is
right and what isn't and deems one side
as as safe and following the science and
the other side which lumps in yes
anti-vaxxers on the far right but also
like scientists from Stanford scientists
from Harvard epidemiologists who had
alternate perspectives on lockdown and
on vaccine safety for example who are
censored but I'm glad Elon Musk has
taken over and reversing some of those
things with the Twitter files and with
changing policy
is the ignorance in naivete of the
pro-censorship left especially on campus
uh these students that want to ban
speech under the banner of hate speech
and that and you know the underlying uh
conceit for all of this is the safety is
conceived that that these wealthy
privileged students are just going
around barely hanging on for their lives
because they're so traumatic traumatized
and so oppressed uh and so therefore
hate speech is going to just push them
over the edge and they're all going to
commit suicide or be killed
um but that they think that they will
always control the reins of power in
order to Define what hate speech is and
they have no understanding of what one
hopes is still neutral principles that
were their ideological enemies to get
hold of that power they would use that
censorship power against them and so so
the only safe haven for this is to have
complete Viewpoint neutrality and let
the sides duke it out but when you start
designating certain types of of
information as misinformation that you
have the right to suppress at some point
the tables will turn one hopes and uh
that same
extraordinarily dangerous and violent
power will be used against you that's a
great segue actually because well
speaking of viewpoint neutrality so
DeSantis comes in and he says hey we
want to keep the internet the promise of
the internet to be what we all thought
20 years ago that you'd basically be
able to get on here and say what you
think and we want to remove from the
schools this indoctrination instead of
Education which is what what's happening
with this AP African-American studies
course that we've been covering all week
where they were also including gender
queer Theory and a whole bunch more so
listen to how the ladies and at the view
and I always have to apologize to my
audience before we play a clip from The
View but here we go listen to how the
ladies of the view are describing what
DeSantis is doing this week
to Harvard and and Yale yes he did so
he's got a very good education now he
doesn't want anybody else to have it you
know
and that's famous right I mean I took it
seriously when Donald Trump said I love
the undereducated the pulley the poorly
educated he said that specifically and I
think that Ron DeSantis is taking you
know that page out of that Playbook
because the less people know
the easier it is for those people to to
sort of Gaslight them and and snooker
them and I think what's so offensive to
me and what you kind of just alluded to
it is that he only targeted
African-American AP students yes that's
right everything else was fair game you
can learn about Latinos you could learn
about Japanese you could learn about
Asia and everybody but not black folks
which are the very Foundation of this
country well those are the ones but
that's the black the black community in
this country has suffered from slavery
that's why we built this country for
free he doesn't I know that are you tell
him I mean he doesn't want people to
know that because they don't make white
people feel that we and we want our
reparations for it
all right putting aside The Joy looks
drunk
um everything Sonny said there was a lie
every single word out of her mouth was a
lie she did not tell you what was going
on in that African-American studies
course they refused to they covered it
every day this week they refused to say
anything about the gender Theory stuff
and also I don't know are there uh after
AP courses in Asian American history I
don't know that it even exists no so it
just it's all complete nonsense Heather
go first I could see you're jumping at
this one
it's amazing it is such a race hustle uh
I'm happy be colorblind but as long as
this race hustle is one-sided at some
point people are going to have to say
we're not putting up with this any
longer we refuse to be ma'am out we
refuse to be guilt-tripped she's lying
there is not that this is the first AP
course in a particular Identity or race
it's precisely because uh we all go
around so terrified of black anger uh
that we've created this course that is
at it we're not political of course
African-American history is an
extraordinarily important part of this
history I I assume it's already being
taught but that of course it's already
being taught it's being taught in every
high school in America without question
without a question but but when this
course so completely unacceptable was
its Embrace of the most shallow ignorant
academic theorizing that has nothing to
do with historical scholarship which is
simply the wrote repetition of a
particularly
jargon-ridden academic discourse that is
made out of air and whose only purpose
is to keep white people feeling guilty
so they keep shoveling benefits and
destroying their own standards uh in
order to placate black rage RAV do you
think that they actually believe what
they're saying you know I'm getting
tired of sort of I always try to go out
of my way to and not impugn people's
motives but at some point like are they
just complete idiots or Liars or is it
like half and half like do they really
do you think have no idea I know you're
not inside their brains but like what do
you think is really going on here there
is an executive producer of that show
who I'm going to try to get on this show
I tweeted Adam obviously he's not going
to do it Brian's something his name is
get me his name and again
um but you know there they and they by
the way they we check they are part of
ABC entertainment not ABC news but what
do you think is really going on there
when they're doing this every day
um
yeah I mean the way that that course was
branded right I mean AP African-American
studies I mean oh if you're if you're
against that then of course I mean
aren't you against black people like I
mean it's a very surface level like
reading where someone just doesn't have
the brain power to actually look like oh
this is not just black history this is
like they're teaching about
intersectionality in the score that's
not rigorous historical scholarship I
mean that's a
you know made up these theorized
concoction within Academia that that is
far more pervasive than I thought by the
way I mean this stuff a lot of people
genuinely believe these things I mean
I've had many many encounters with
people at my own University I'm I
decided to go back to school by the way
and I'm I'm a halftime uh student there
here locally and it's like time and time
again I have these encounters I mean
there was one Professor a couple years
ago
um they were gonna create some kind of
club or some kind of round table for
students to come and talk about race
issues and one of the core elements of
this round table was systemic racism and
I asked this professor whose name I was
I'm escaping she was also South Asian
like me and I said hey
um I don't exactly agree with the
premise about the structural like racism
I think it's too simplistic am I still
welcome at this table and she was like
no sorry no no you gotta accept as this
that the biblical foundational truth of
Canadian history otherwise you're not
welcome here and it's like I wanted to
make this point earlier about like
Jordan Peterson he's coming on campus or
he's coming to Vancouver on Tuesday and
there were talks about inviting him on
campus
um one Professor who's an old school
liberal who actually disagrees with
Peterson on many things and agrees with
other things he just tossed around the
idea like maybe we should invite him on
campus like uh behind the scenes in a
staff meeting and the younger professors
in the sociology and political science
departments obviously said well we'll
hold a protest if you're going to invite
Peterson on campus so how dare you how
dare you even suggest that idea given
how you know racist and transphobic and
whatever Jordan Peterson is and
meanwhile I'm having other encounters
with philosophy professors in my classes
who are saying like Peterson's this like
hardcore anti-intellectual who doesn't
know how to read I mean this is the
extent to which Academia is just plagued
by this Dei woke ideology I mean I I
thought that it would be far less
pervasive than it's turned out to be in
my case and I'm just continually just
troubled by this ideological monoculture
where if you just step outside of it if
you just disagree a little bit then
suddenly you're a heretic the idea that
a professor of course everyone's allowed
to protest but the idea that a professor
would be protesting because Jordan
Peterson the most probably the most
serious academic certainly the most
well-known academic we have in the world
who has brought more good ideas just the
biblical stuff alone back into the world
more than most religious Scholars all
combined in the last 50 years have done
and that they'd be wasting their time
protesting on him is or protesting him
is absolutely insane by the way the the
ep the executive producer of The View
I'll look at the camera Brian tetta
executive producer of The View I would
love to have you on the show I will do
it without notes we can do it live
whenever you want to do it we can air it
during the view or after the view or
before the view and I'd like to talk to
you about your journalistic integrity
when you set up the show every day what
topics you give to the girls and what
research goes into it and whether you
have any opinions on the fact that they
share misinformation every day so Brian
tetta you are welcome on the Reuben
report at any point and that's a good
segue to our final clip which of course
is from The View and listen to these the
high level discourse on what's going on
here in Florida this is soil shopton
there I think that these people these
fascists out there like DeSantis they
think that we're just going to sit back
and let them do whatever they want no
we're not we've been we've seen this
movie before okay those of us who lived
in the 60s and 70s yeah we saw this
movie there was many there were many
many fascist tactics coming down the the
pike from Nixon and the rest to these
fascists that's what they are and and we
protested and we protested and we ended
a war that was illegal and we we did
stuff and it's happening again that's
the goodness it's not happening it's not
happening enough in Florida
first though wait I've said it many
times but I'm told that I live about
five minutes away from Anna Navarro and
I just cannot wait to meet this woman
somewhere why is she living in this
fascist State why doesn't she leave I
have no idea but Heather it's like what
the high hell is Joy talking about what
fascist takeover is Rhonda Sanderson
what war does Ron DeSantis want us to go
to all he's doing is pushing back it
really is that simple
I I guess Bahar is like in some time
warp she doesn't look like it but she
seems to be maybe still a 14 year old
her level of of intellectual
sophistication is is you know that low
and these were the people who were
complaining at the beginning of of
DeSantis not wanting people to be
educated right right I mean the the lack
of knowledge of what fascism actually
means this is just absolute knee-jerk
smear now I'm I'm always asking myself
Dave
they would say the same about us you
know let's just be honest they would say
that we are just as knee-jerk in our use
of blanket epithets uh and so I I always
sort of probe like do we do the same
thing in calling them I don't know I
mean we call them totalitarians they
they would they do want to shut down
speech
one one could debate that I mean one
would need evidence on both sides sure
let's just say in this case though uh
it's it's completely ludicrous the idea
that Nixon was a fascist she's again
she's talking like the 60s this was the
the moment in the 60s when you had the
rise of youth culture you had a
capitalist system that was so wildly
successful that it gave teenagers
spending power and power for the first
time in all of human history and it went
downhill from there you know you had
corporations creating youth culture and
and these these idiots we still have it
ordering adults around and she never
grew up she never gained some
perspective of what actual threats of
government power are you know Heather I
think you're making a great point about
can we fall into that trap as well and
and I'm not saying that we don't and I
call them silly names especially on
Twitter too but I would say one one
clear distinction from people on the
right and people on the left that I that
I see almost not obviously not
exclusively but fairly consistently is
that when something like the don't say
gay Bill the quote unquote don't say
Gabriel I'm using their language that
already proves it when it happens HB I
think it was 1447 or whatever it was
which had nothing to do with being gay
and it was all about parental rights and
education on this show I repeatedly
explained what it was said my position
and then showed their position my
frustration with them is they never say
what the thing is they just use the it's
don't say gay or they got rid of as Rob
said you get rid of African-American
studies well who APM African-American is
you obviously are racist they never
explain the other thing so I don't know
that it's like I don't think it's quite
50 50. I'm not saying you were saying
that but I think that is a substantive
difference uh RAV uh fascism it's here
apparently in Florida where everyone I
know is happy
yeah I I just want to quickly applaud
like what's happening in Florida I mean
The State Journal the state general
sorry the Surgeon General yesterday yeah
sent a great letter to the FDA saying
that more and more concerns about
Adverse Events from the vaccine have
risen and you should seriously like
consider what's going on here I mean
Florida has led the way on covid it's
just incredible
um how many people left and right have
supported them in what they've done
compared to Blue States
um but this whole thing about language I
mean
what one often comes across this
allegation of conspiracy theory on the
right which exists on the fringes
absolutely you know stolen election
anti-vax sentiment you know vaccines are
killing millions of people etc etc but a
lot of these ideas are completely
deranged conspiracy theory too I mean
again like this whole racial Gap stuff
that Heather and I have written about
like every time there's a racial
disparity while it must be racism right
if you're if you're against this AP
African-American studies course you're
obviously racist if you have questions
about mRNA vaccines you're obviously an
anti-vaxxer right that's the definition
of conspiracy theory right when you
don't have evidence of a claim and you
continually make that claim without
adequate evidence supporting your
position the the left you know the far
left continually does that to their
opponent their opponents and they
continually just bend language and throw
around allegations without any
sufficient proof you know I would say
Dave another aspect of our of our world
and and that's a very interesting
distinction that the the right tries at
least to lay out what the other side's
argument is and the facts before getting
into its own argument the other thing
that I've been going nuts with recently
is who owns the default uh it seems like
no matter how radical and lunatic an
idea that the left puts forward it
immediately becomes the default
assumption and to argue against it you
then have the burden of proof so the the
you know Locust classicus of this is of
course trans ideology that within a few
years all of a sudden the default
assumption in in Elite Progressive
circles which are very very wide circles
is that of course sex and gender are
artificial constructs there's something
merely assigned at Birth by an
obstetrician and that children should
have their noses rubbed into premature
knowledge of sexuality and I you know
regardless of what kind of sexuality it
is I think that is child abuse to strip
children of that innocence but that now
becomes the default as somebody who does
still subject yourself to the New York
Times I watch this all the time and it
is those who argue against it that are
seen as marginal it's it's a very weird
uh and and Incredibly important move
that they're making because in law uh we
know whoever has the burden of proof in
a case yes they're up against a higher
evidentiary standard and so you know
what law is all about is often burden
shifting you know can you shift the
burden onto the other side and and
that's what one of the things that we're
up against when you can issue your
challenge to the executive producer of
The View but we're still the underdog
here and and he can ignore you and the
the challenge is to get big enough and
to control or have access to enough
power in the media sphere and the
information sphere that they do have to
answer your challenge well last month we
just found out this morning I got an
email from my guy was our best month
ever across every platform by 64 percent
not not nine percent not 16 64 so maybe
it's happening uh by the way the what
you're describing there a lot of people
call that factory settings that sort of
the the factory settings of what we all
come out of in the west is a sort of
leftist indoctrination and then the rest
of us have to constantly be be
hatcheting away at that thing uh guys I
have thoroughly enjoyed this panel I
will gladly have you both back uh
anytime you want Heather thank you very
much Rob thank you will link to your
stuff down below I've got a post game
show coming up in about 42 seconds we
leave you with a cold close have a great
weekend everybody
thank you hello
[Music]
hello
thank you
[Music]